on October 31st 2016
the Swedish city of Malmo hosted a joint
commemoration of the 500th anniversary
of the Protestant Reformation even Pope
Francis traveled to Sweden to attend the
ceremonies Catholics and Protestants are
looking back together on the five
centuries since Martin Luther posted his
famous 95 theses
the event was organized by the Lutheran
World Federation which was founded in
1947 in the Swedish city of lund
as we continue our journey from conflict
to communion the gospel of the Lord
I am The True Vine and my father is the
wine grower among the hosts was the
Archbishop of the Church of Sweden
Antioch Alain the head of one of the
world's largest Lutheran communities to
make it burn more through
this wasn't the first time the Pope in
the archbishop had met in May 2015
Antonia Killeen visited the pontiff in
Rome she was the first female Archbishop
ever to be received in the Vatican the
castle and the two spires of the
Cathedral or the picturesque landmarks
of the small city of Uppsala near
Stockholm this is where Archbishop
jacqueline has received
at just under 120 meters the Uppsala
Cathedral is the tallest religious
building in Scandinavia the city was
once a major center of power in Sweden
twelve kings were crowned here
Bob sama has retained its importance as
a center of religion since 2014 the
Church of Sweden has been headed by a
woman it's the first time that's been
the case in the church's centuries long
history
what's my business bono what has always
been important to me is that church
services are the center of Christian
life and should project the joy of being
Christians I talk a lot about the joy of
services avoider I'll start again for
got his teens to the Church of Sweden
has its headquarters near the Cathedral
this is Antigua Colin's office
decker lane has a doctorate in theology
she's convinced that religious work
should be closely connected with
politics culture and science
what's on episode 18 perspectiva cameras
are from my own personal perspective I
want to believe with my rational mind
and not in spite of it from a larger
perspective I would say that the
knowledge of faith theology the
experience of faith and our faith and
trust in knowledge including the Natural
Sciences and science in general is
jointly responsible for the goodness in
the world at 61 ya Killeen is the 70th
Archbishop of Uppsala that makes her the
highest representative of a Lutheran
community that encompasses six million
Swedes Sweden's Lutheran community is
one of the largest in the world at least
60 percent of the population are members
of the church
yuck Elaine is German she was born in
1955 in the small town of Attica in the
west of the country she first came to
Apsara to pursue her studies and she
never returned to Germany she has little
family there
her parents are deceased and her
daughter's live in Sweden with families
of their own
after her studies Jacqueline spent some
time teaching in the US but then decided
to return to Sweden to work as a clergy
woman hi
Alstom home and its site the concept of
home has changed for me over time it's
less about a geographical place than the
experience of time wherever I feel a
sense of belonging I feel at home much
Nakumatt women have been allowed to
serve as clergy in Sweden since 1959 of
Sweden's 13 diocese two are headed by
female bishops Jacqueline herself was
Bishop of London for seven years
despite the large number of church
members Sweden is a secular country
where interest in religion is declining
even the name Martin Luther has lost its
context for many Swedes
that's come that I can stop on they were
flat it depends on whom you ask there
are some who here Lutheran say Martin
Luther King there are people who have no
relationship to Luther any kind of it
but Swedish culture contains the common
notion of Luther sitting on your
shoulder it's meant as a reminder to
keep things from getting to and remind
us of our duties those need to foil it
to get on actually these concepts have
more to do with const orthodoxy and
pietism then with the real Luther if you
can use such a phrase that surprised me
about Sweden
I think Sweden is unique in maintaining
this boring sad dark image of Luther
instead of the lively colorful and
complex figure that's truer to history
Mia the devil hydrants pleased
500 years ago the Lutheran Reformation
forever changed how many people
approached faith and religion the center
of this revolution was the eastern
German town of beaten back Luther
preached his sermons at the town and
parish church of st. Mary's point is not
to idealize Luther but to understand his
objectives and put them into
contemporary terms in the context of
personal liberation through Scripture
it's about what connects us today and
what it means to preach and live
liberation liberation was a
controversial idea back in Luther's day
just as it still is sometimes today I
think that's one of the constraints we
experience in our world is consumerism
increasingly in our relationships were
treated as customers and not autonomous
fellow citizens that's also sometimes
the case in church so one of our aims is
to investigate what it means to be a
member of society
June 2016 Jacqueline has come to
Wittenberg as a delegate for a meeting
of the Council of the Lutheran World
Federation
so today let us invite each other to
remember our baptism at a Mother Church
of the Reformation the place where
Martin Luther regularly preached in the
place where the spiritual journey of the
Reformation began we are invited to
remember the beginning of our own
spiritual journey
the conference was held in bitten bags
scoffs delegates discussed not only the
preparations for the 500th anniversary
of the Reformation in 2017 but also
fundamental issues like the significance
of religion and church in the present
day globalized world
the Lutheran World Federation has its
headquarters in Geneva Switzerland it
brings together 145 churches from 98
countries 72 million people worldwide
are members the fact that together we
help take care of 2 million refugees is
something that makes an impression and
is a true expression of our faith and
our identity sana in late August this
time guests from all over the world have
come here a new bishop is being ordained
it's a special day for everyone
including Archbishop jackeline it's a
rare occasion for her to Don her festive
garments
the entire event reminds Jacqueline of
June 15 2014 when she received the
Archbishop's insignia and became the
head of the Church of Sweden
the social none melodica tough
I was before it was a wonderful day what
I remember most was the great sense of
joy that came over so many people in
part that was because I was the first
female Archbishop there was so much joy
when the official part of the ceremony
was over there were celebrations and
applause in the cathedral it was
overwhelming the warmth support and
positive expectations gave me a strength
I still feel will do a good stand tree
in Islam
Oh target I hope draw at war abisco oh
you tava data saw at beautifully errand
shuriken Oh peaked or Goods Vilia for
berkeley got Evelyn today's Iran de la
vie is being ordained Bishop of Carthage
at age 47 he's unusually young for the
office
Oh sir and all of a big TV scope Tony
mood Hannam some Christie sand bed
okay you're looking at me okay
it's Donna B's big day the mood is
excellent it's always great when
representatives of the Worldwide Church
are here it makes us feel that as Church
of Sweden we are part of a global church
symbolic gestures of togetherness are
important
the church is losing more and more
members there's a lot of work to be done
I would say that we are in a very
interesting point because we are I think
we are more important than than we think
ourselves I think when it comes to
values when it comes to what happens in
society today
I think the Swedish church has a lot to
offer and to give them and and I think
we are one of the fundaments in in the
Swedish society there's a reception at
the Archbishop's residence this is where
ya Killeen lives and receives people in
her office as the head of the church as
usual yeah Colleen and her husband Heinz
greet their guests together
he too is German and actually came to
Sweden first
people often say to me your wife is the
archbishop then you're just a pasture
how can you stand out but I don't have a
problem with it my always jokin as a man
I can only live if I'm married to a
beautiful and clever woman comics Newell
even then if I had ever been made I like
the shaitaan' or Shirin flower
her future husband was the main reason
Angela Carlene stayed on after her first
semester at masada University in 1977 I
think things would have been very
different if I were alone it's important
to have the feeling that there's someone
there who shares my joy who puts up with
me if I'm tired or in a bad mood and who
accepts it if I'm bothered by something
or gets stressed out but someone who can
also say hey you're not listening to me
it hurts me I got the yucca lanes met
not far from the Archbishop's residence
where they now live
toughing son this one these walls that's
where it started in that house on our
anniversaries we can go out on this
little balcony here with a glass of
champagne look over there and then look
each other in the eye and drink a toast
back in our day that house was part of
the theology department elegy in fact
with it
the yucca liens moved around a lot they
were constantly on the go and had to get
used to new surroundings first time
Jacqueline gave up his job as a pastor
in Sweden so that they could go to
Chicago where his wife worked and taught
as a geologist
one of her main interests was
temporality
until you Colleen's doctoral thesis was
titled time and eternity the question of
time in church science and theology in
1999 she received her doctorate from
Lourdes University
if time is all there is and it's lost
its connection to eternity the result is
stress the pressure to experience things
and a culture of acceleration in which
we think that things are automatically
better if they're faster that can have
direct negative consequences if you've
gotten accustomed to acceleration you
experience every obstacle as something
bad and that can lead for instance to
xenophobia since encounters with
something foreign mean that you have to
slow down it's an obstacle to
acceleration it requires time
the Church of Sweden like churches in
many places has to deal with a growing
disinterest in religion most Swedes
consider religion a private matter that
makes it difficult for the church to
start a public dialogue about religious
topics until 2000 the Church of Sweden
was a state church and until around 1994
Swedish schools taught the basics of the
Christian faith when that stopped the
church didn't step up and say now we
have to take responsibility we just let
the situation slide a bit and now we
have the situation that schools provide
some orientation about religion in
general but not from the standpoint that
all of us have some sort of relationship
to a tradition of faith and we have very
few households in which children are
socialized as Christians part of the
tradition of the Church of Sweden is its
relationship to the Swedish royal family
whether it's King Cod Gustav xvi or
someone else a member of the royal
family attends almost all major church
events
the archbishop is also usually on hand
for major occasions of the royal family
like at the baptism of Prince Alexander
in September 2016
as a strong lager visa focus there's a
certain amount of public interest and
excitement but the main thing is that
it's a religious service which expresses
joy and gratitude and the prince will
receive a gift that is the best one can
get even as a prince
shortening horn phallus in stock on the
baptism takes place in a small chapel
traditionally the Swedish royal family
belongs to the Church of Sweden so the
duties of the Archbishop's include
conducting royal weddings and baptizing
new members of the royal family
don't piss mushroom fit you I think it
was nice for him he was very attentive
and when he heard the words Jesus Christ
the crucified and resurrected calls you
to become his disciple he wiggled around
and his eyes opened wide by the
Gothenburg Book Fair the four-day event
takes place every year in late September
and attracts a hundred thousand visitors
it's the biggest cultural event in
Scandinavia
the book fair is also an important event
for Angela Killeen she's in constant
demand as a discussion partner here
there is great interest in her as a
person and in what the church has to say
she gladly takes the chance to
communicate with people directly and
this year she's published a new book a
collection of essays and sermons the
autograph session is packed
for many years the Church of Sweden has
had the Book Fairs largest space for
readings and panels every 30 minutes
there's a new discussion the archbishop
is both a host and a guest the space is
always full
it's a common belief that Sweden is a
very secular country which is true in
some respects but there's another side
to it and you see it on occasions like
this this year media interest was
particularly intense a few months ago
yeah Killeen was attacked on Twitter
accused of letting others write parts of
her books what happened on Twitter in
the case of the archbishop yeah Killian
is just a small sign of what has
happened globally in media and in the
public sphere where there's a disregard
today for facts I mean there's a person
who can say basically whatever he or she
wants on a big scale you can see this in
the case of Donald Trump for instance
you can say whatever lies he wants you
could see it in the brexit referendum in
Great Britain as well and no matter on
how you you you contest to these lies
they are the facts are disregarded so
the lies keep on living in Sweden we
lack discussions and conversations on a
high intellectual level and in those
circumstances it's easy for distortions
caricatures and half-truths to pass
themselves off as the truth
September 2016 the General Synod in ops
Ana's new conference center
representatives from Sweden's 13 diocese
are advising on the future challenges
faced by the church the discussions go
on behind closed doors one of the most
important topics is how the church and
Swedish society should deal with other
cultures and religions
Archbishop Angela Colleen is popular
among both lutheran clergy and the
general populace in Sweden but she also
faces considerable resistance on topics
like environmentalism education and
xenophobia nevertheless her focus with
an eye towards the anniversary of the
Reformation remains on the ecumenical
dialog between Protestants and Catholics
the joint ceremony on October 31st 2016
was a powerful sign that the anniversary
is important to all Christians
my kind of [ __ ] up saying there's no
overlooking the fact that this is the
first time on a global level the
Reformation has been jointly
commemorated I think the long-term
influence of the event will only become
apparent in retrospect
you